so here I've got a really nice sample
silicon all right yeah I'm going to take
it out of the bowl at that I'm going to
have to wash my hands after so silicon
is a very common element it's
particularly found in sand which is the
oxide of silica that's the compound of
oxygen and silicon it's also found in a
variety of minerals which contains
silicon oxygen and another metal which
are known as silicates and silicates
occur in an enormous number of different
minerals it's the thought of part of
science that unless you're specialists
you find quite boring but if you really
go into it like everything else it
becomes really quite interesting so this
is a piece of poly crystalline silicon
it's a really quite fantastic element
and it's very often used on in fact it's
used very regularly to make electronic
components all of the computers that we
use in actually the camera that you're
recording me on now are based upon
silicon technology
silicon is also extremely important and
the basis of most of the electronic
devices we will use my watch your video
camera and also in computers and if we
look over here I've got here this is an
example of a silicon wafer you can see
at the back this is silicon so the
silicon is grown as a single crystal
from which we can then make very very
highly refined architectures on silicon
chips but you see here we've got a poly
crystalline sample so it's very pretty
the way that it interacts with the light
and you can see the different grain
sizes so let me take that did Martin
show you the single crystal the wafer
yeah yeah because if you get the light
coming off it you can get also it's like
different color defects here you can see
this is pure silicon on the back and on
the front people have grown chips these
are the Pentium 4 chips for the computer
I think I'm not absolutely sure but I
think these are the chips and these are
connectors on either side so they're
whole lot of these chips and they grow
large number of them at once
these are chopped up and tested and the
ones that worked are put into computers
the ones that are no no good are just
chapped and so this is a fantastically
delicate and piece of engineering making
these this is so-called 20 centimeter
wafer they now make silicon chips on the
30 centimeter wafer which is about this
size and you can get large number more
on them if you get a single crystal of
this silicon structure it can it can
defrag the light and change the light to
refract and bends off at different
angles and you get like a rainbow effect
of it it's really quite beautiful
compound of silicon silicon nitride is
extremely tough and very light so it's
very difficult to break and silicon
nitride for example is used in the
impellers in turbochargers in cars so
when you put your foot down on the
accelerator it will spin up very fast
because it's very light it's very strong
so it went suddenly fall to bits as its
revving up inside your engine right I'm
going to put that there if I want to put
that back in the bag